welcome back to CBS this morning
Saturday we begin this half-hour with
more action to remove symbols associated
with racism and oppression overnight the
only statue of a Confederate General in
Washington DC was toppled demonstrators
wrapped chains around the statute of
Albert Pike pulled it to the ground and
set it ablaze similar reckonings are
happening in Great Britain as well and
as Roxana Saberi reports some
institutions are acknowledging ties to
systemic racism that are centuries old
from the streets to the boardrooms of
big businesses and now even the pulpit
pressure is growing on Britain to
confront its racist past the Church of
England apologized this week after
reports that dozens of clergymen
benefited from slavery in the 18th and
19th centuries the UK's central bank is
pledging to remove any portraits of its
former directors and governors linked to
the slave trade the firm Lloyd's of
London which used to ensure slave ships
says it will donate to charities for
racial minorities in a prominent pub
cane whose founder Benjamin green own
plantations in the Caribbean says it
will invest in communities of color many
of these institutions have known about
their links to slavery in one way or
another for a very long time and they
really should have been doing something
about this that long time ago Keith
McClelland oversees an online database
at University College London listing
tens of thousands of individuals across
the British Empire linked to the slave
trade when Britain abolished slavery in
1833 the government paid them for their
losses your research has been out there
for years why do you think it's
resonating so much now it's a black
lives matter the movement has spread
from the u.s. to the UK protestor Aaron
Ellington
have you faced racism personally many
times
stores being stopped inserts to be asked
specific questions that will not be
asked to a group of people in the sense
of different color racial injustice
persists across British society as a
legacy of slavery McClellan says and
apologizing isn't enough concrete
proposals concrete actions education
training whole series of things needs to
be a need to be implemented but he says
acknowledging the uncomfortable past is
a step in the right direction for CBS
this morning Saturday Roxana Saberi
London